[Music]
there's so many reasons
very awesome
[Music]
for some of them to be abused is
unforgivable really
um i know a lot of that has come from
abroad you know
the people that track those things have
been able to
explain that um but not all of it and
um it's just not what we stand for
we we i think have been a
a beacon of light in bringing people
together
in people being able to relate to the
national team
and the national team stands for
everybody and
um so that togetherness has to continue
and we've shown
the power our country has when it does
come together and has that
energy and positivity together we felt
that from the fans
and i'm incredibly proud of the players
[Music]
that was really sad like it's a sad
morning for us all anyway isn't it you
know we dared to dream yesterday
and uh our hopes with the dashed but to
wake up to this it's kind of
it's more depressing isn't it like that
we live in a in a country where
this kind of response is you know the
new normal now isn't
this racism
you